So, in fact, it's actually quite easy to illicit false memories in the
laboratory. This is often done with word list. So, people are presented a list
of words that they have to recall later on. And often, they remember words that
were not on the original list, but were associated similar to words that were
on the list. So in fact they've created a false memory, a memory of a word that
wasn't there. So then the question is, why is this important, who should care?
So one reason it's so important to demonstrate the ease of creating false
memories in the laboratory is that it has real world ramifications, especially
in court cases. Occasionally false memories lead to false accusations. In one
case, a woman who was raped accused a psychologist by the name of Donald
Thompson of the rape. As it turns out she'd been watching t.v. Right before her
attack and on TV she was watching Donald Thompson, who in fact was talking
about, of all things false memories. Now in her mind the association between
the attack and Donald Thompson's face was made. So she made this accusation.
Now as it turns out Donald Thompson, of course, had a great alibi. He could
prove beyond a shadow of the doubt that he was on TV at the time and was not
there in committing a crime. Unfortuneately, not everyone who is falsely
accused has such a alibi. Occassionally, false memories lead to false
accusations and convictions.